مرحبا بكم في هذه النافذه الانسانيه
الخاصه وفيها نناقش عرقله قوات الاحتلال
دخول المساعدات الى قطاع غزه وشح
المساعدات التي تدخل وما يسببه ذلك من
تداعيات خطيره على الوضع الصحي والغذائي
ولمناقشة
اذ قالت وزاره الصحه ان عدد الشهداء ارتفع
الى
21320 شهيدا بينهم
8800 طفل اضافه الى
6300 امراه بينما وصل عدد الجرحى الى
5563 مصابين منذ السابع من اكتوبر الماضي
هناك ايضا 7000 مفقود تحت الانقاض او ان
مصيرها لاء مجهول الى حد الان و 70% من
المفقودين هم من الاطفال والنساء في ملف
المساعدات قال المدير العام للمكتب
الاعلامي الحكومي في وقت سابق ان
المساعدات التي تدخل من معبر رفح لا تغطي
سوى 2% فقط من الاحتياجات واشار المدير
العام للمكتب الاعلامي الحكومي لانه قبل
الحرب كانت تدخل 600 شاحنه الى قطاع غزه
في اليوم رغم حصار وقال انه تدخل اليوم في
هذه المرحله من 70 الى 100 شاحنه فقط نصف
هذه الشاحنات هي عباره عن قماش واغطيه
وفرشات والنصف الاخر عباره عن مياه واشياء
بسيطه ولفت الى ان اكثر من 9000 شخص
استشهدوا نتيجه عدم قدره المستشفيات اجراء
العمليات وبسبب انعدام الادويه ينضم الينا
ايضا من مستشفى ناصر الطبي في خان يونس
الدكتور ناهض ابو طعيمه مدير مستشفى
الجراحه في مجمع ناصر الطبي دكتور ناهد شح
المساعدات لا سما الطبيه منها كيف يؤثر
على ادائ لعملكم في ظل هذا التدفق الكبير
لعدد الشهداء والجرحى
للمستشفيات نعم مجمع ناصر الطبي يستقبل
يوميا العديد والمزيد من الاصابات
والشهداء اليوم استقبل مجمع ناصر الطبي 18
شهيدا و25 اصابه جديده ومازال الاقسام وما
زالت الاقسام في المجمع ممتلئه ومزدحم
بالمصابين والذين يحتاجون الى تدخلات
جراحيه عديده وتدخلات جراحيه متتاليه
نعم نعاني الان من نقص من كثير من الاصناف
التي نحتاجها في العمليات الجراحيه اي نقص
حال وهذا يؤثر على تقديم الخدمه في اقسام
العمليات
الان ينقصنا كثير جدا الشاش المعقم في
داخل اقسام العمليات
ينقصنا مثبتات العظم الخارجي ينقصنا
الكثير من ادويه التخدير التي نحتاجها في
تقدير المرضى في اقسام العمليات طيب ابرز
الحالات الموجوده لديكم في مستشفى ناصر
والتي تحتاج الى عمليات جراحيه عاجله وكيف
يتم التعاطي مع هذا
الواقع
كثير من الحالات التي تحتاج الى عمليات
جراحيه هي عمليات عظام بالدرجه الاولى
عمليات جراحه مخ واعصاب
عمليات جراحه عمود فقري عمليات جراحه عامه
يوميا نجري من 20 الى 30 عمليه جراحيه ما
بين خطيره جدا حالاتهم وصفت بالخطير
جدا الكثير منها تستهلك مستلزمات
ومستهلكات طبيه كثيره خلافا على الغيارات
اليوميه التي يحتاجها الجرحى والمصابون
داخل اقسام المبيت هذه كلها تحتاج الى
مستهلكات ومستلزمات
طبيه ويوجد نقص احد فيها في في الفتره
الحاليه طيب مما تطلبون ما نسبه ما يصلكم
من مساعدات من من الاطار العام للحاجات
الاساسيه
[موسيقى]
لديكم نطلب من الجميع توفير المستلزمات
والمستهلكات
الطبيه لكي نستمر في تقديم الخدمه الطبيه
للمصابين والجرحى في داخل اقسام المبيت
واقسام العمليات والعت المركزه طلبنا من
المؤسسات الدوليه توفير ما يلزم من هذه من
هذه المستلزمات والمستهلكات
الطبيه الا ان ما يصلنا هو القليل القليل
والذي لا يلب احتياجات المجمع كون المجمع
الان يخدم شريحه كبيره من المواطنين والمص
الذين يترددون على المجمع باستمرار شكرا
لك سيد ناهد ابو طعيمه مدير مستشفى
الجراحه في مجمع ناصر الطبي كنت معنا من
مستشفى ناصر الطبي في خان يونس ختام هذه
النافذه الانسانيه الى
اللقاء